I is very student from potions and
tremulous my question is why do some
particles like blue ones do not have
must also have they been observed
experimentally hi Rajesh so you asked
why do some particles like gluons have
no mass why are gluons massless and have
they been observed experimentally well
the answer to why they're massless is
very interesting they're massless for
the same reason that quanta of light
photons are massless why light is
massless why it travels at the speed of
light gluons are massless for the same
reason both electromagnetism and quantum
chromodynamics are consequences of a
deep symmetry of nature recall it gauge
invariance it is a local symmetry of
nature which in effect tells us that the
space of labels of particles in the case
of charged particles it's a very simple
phase of a wave function of charged
particles in the case of quarks or
gluons it's a space of colored labels
that these that the laws of physics are
invariant under local rotations in that
space and that beautiful local symmetry
of nature leads to the dynamical laws
for both light on the one hand and
gluons on the other hand it is the under
line symmetry of the theory of
electromagnetism in the one hand and
of quantum chromodynamics on the other
hand so it is really impossible work
very difficult to imagine that the
photon the quanta of light was had a
very little mass that would totally
break this symmetry and for the same
reason it's impossible to imagine that
gluons have a very little mass now if
the symmetry is there and we believe it
is these particles must be truly
massless now if they're massless like
light rays why haven't we seen them
streaming throughout the universe well
the reason we haven't seen them is that
unlike light rays gluons have charge as
well not only are they that carriers of
the force between charged particles like
quarks they also carry charge themselves
so they pull on each other
gluons are attracted to gluons and
they're held together by the strong
nuclear force which gets to be quite
strong at very smart small distances so
the gluons much like the quarks are
trapped within nuclei the proton is made
out of inside the proton there are
quarks and gluons moving around and the
gluons never get out even though they're
massless and are traveling at the speed
of light they are also held together by
this very strong force and never get out
of the proton that's why you've never
seen a gluon directly but indirectly we
do see gluons when we smash together two
protons what happens is that the quarks
inside those bags of quarks and gluons
collide produce gluons those gluons are
shot out of the collision but they can't
get out freely themselves because
they're attracted to all the other
gluons and quarks and what comes out is
a jet of ordinary particles which are
totally neutral have
this net charge but we see the Jets that
the gluon turned has turned into and by
by observing the properties of these
Jets we can tell that those Jets came
from one single blue
so in effect in these experiments we see
the gluons or the more precisely the
Jets into which they be which they
eventually become and in that way we
indirectly see gluons